E aí
[Música]
eu
trago aqui hoje o segredo do Sucesso mas
sucesso para uma pessoa ou para outra
não aqui dentro dessa mala eu tenho
segredo para todo mundo que tiver
assistindo presencial digital mas eu
acho que a gente conta uma revelação
dessa né do Sucesso da felicidade da
vida plena preciso de um pouco de
preparo é justamente isso que a gente
vai fazer antes né Eu queria fazer uma
pergunta Quem de vocês não precisa nem
me responder em voz alta que ela não
passar vergonha mas quem de vocês
sonhou penso assim nossa eu quero muito
são luzzer e para quem não sabe o que é
um luz é aquela pessoa que é um perdedor
aquela que a gente pode faltar Dinho não
foi nada na vida né ai que dó alguém te
via te dar uma oportunidade para essa
pessoa luz era isso eu acredito que
mentalmente vocês responderam Não eu
nunca sonhei você é isso né Assim como o
que a Dona Maria Esses são os meus avós
eles trabalhavam na roça colhendo café
vamos analfabetos E aí eles decidiram
que eles não queriam mais a sua vida na
onde morava em Minas Gerais ele senhora
Poxa Vamos fazer um negócio melhor na
sua vida vamos Busca da Felicidade do
Sucesso da Alegria fizeram as malas como
eles não tinham mal Eles colocaram a
lata de farinha de baixo do braço monte
de filho com muito mais coragem do que
juízo chega ao fórum para o Paraná
chegando no Paraná adivinha só não tinha
uma super placa dizendo assim bem vindo
sucesso tá aqui e eles viveram extrema
miséria eles viveram em casa de saber
Olha que curioso a casa de Sapé uma
espécie de capim né que você faz a liga
assim com terra e minha avó conta que
tinha baratinha dentro da casa pior que
isso tem uma tia minha que disse que
tinha cobra Imagina você dormir uma cama
que tem cobra embaixo punk né E a minha
mãe que nasceu o WhatsApp decidiu que
ela não queria aquilo para a vida ela
não sabia muito bem o que ela queria da
vida mas aquilo ela não queria e ela
decidiu falou assim olha Então vou
buscar e vejo é sempre uma busca
geográfica né eu vou em outro lugar ser
feliz aqui não dá Vou em outro lugar ser
feliz aqui não dá quem não tá certo e
ela decidiu um pouco mais longe ela foi
para Europa na casa de uma tia
chegando lá na Europa também não tinha
plaquinha de boas vindas para ela de
sucesso Que coisa né de novo sucesso não
tava lá então ela vou privada fez uma
série de trabalho ficar fala puxando que
não era isso que eu esperava e ela
conheceu uma pessoa muito especial José
Manuel um filósofo que disse para ela
nilziane não seria legal Pensa aqui
comigo estudar ela não nunca tinha tido
estímulo para que os pais analfabeto
muito guerreiros né poxa Sei lá vou
perguntar e ela decidiu só que como ela
não sabia muito que caminho escolher ela
desse o texto até hoje eu pego sua mãe
mas o que que era ela não sabe dona
Nilza não sabe o que que era mas ela
chegou lá o primeiro dia e disse que
chegou e ela passou em frente a primeira
aula a gente ela já desistiu na primeira
aula mas não foi por uma motivo ruim ela
chegou e ela passou em frente a uma
portinha viu pessoal de jaleco branco e
falou eu é isso que eu quero ser não
sabia muito bem o que é E aí ela começou
a estudar Química voltou para o Brasil
terminou esse relacionamento voltou para
o Brasil e chegou aqui ela foi a
primeira formada da família se tornar
engenheira química e ela quando voltou
ela conseguiu comprar a casa ela
conseguiu comprar carro todo mundo olhou
para com outros olhos para educação
falou caramba olha o que a Nilza
conseguiu fazer ele virou meio que
referência né todo mundo achava Neuza
inteligente a Neuza fez faculdade e aí
eu tenho um fenômeno interessante
curioso aqui que todo mundo chegar a
química né E aí assim você não pode ser
outra coisa é química e aí você é
engraçada porque que se você quiser
fazer qualquer outra graduação e esse
viu não química e aí só que eles
acreditavam que isso mesmo que tá no DNA
né não sou filha da Nilza tem que ser
nerd tem que ser inteligente não é
possível E aí eles esqueceram que não é
bem assim com o esquema funciona eu no
auge dos meus 15 16 anos meu maior sonho
dúvida vocês adivinharem era trabalhar
em uma loja de shopping não qualquer
lojas loja de surf para poder pegar os
gatinhos Olha só né e com toda a sua
mentalidade né de super abundância de
crescimento as 17 eu engravidei e eu
engravidei eu morava na na casa dos meus
avós na época minha mãe morava em São
Paulo já tinha se estabelecida e eu
morava com os meus avós que eu não
queria sair de Curitiba uma amava
Curitiba e aí chegando lá meu avô disse
assim Camila muito muito carinhosamente
nessas imaginam ele disse eu você casa
ou você vaza e eu pensei a felicidade
tem outro lugar
eu jurava que ele tem outro lugar
e aí decidi que eu ia vazar Esse é meu
avô senhor que já não está mais entre
nós e isso e foi muito marcante para mim
essa busca Eu liguei para minha mãe
falei mas você mora em São Paulo com
você fazer sei lá o quê não sei foi e
chegando em São Paulo eu me desesperei
quando eu não vi a plaquinha de boas
vindas dizendo sucesso está aqui porque
o sucesso não tá em um lugar ele tava
antes de mais nada dentro do que a gente
busca que a gente desperta mas eu não
sabia disso e lembro que quando eu
cheguei em São Paulo o diabo
absolutamente tudo e todos tá gente
odiava sotaque Paulista Eu odiava
trabalhava na Vila Olímpia para quem
nunca foi para ver o Olimpo eo mundo de
prédio o pessoal de salto alto e eu
lembro que eu fui fazer uma entrevista
lá torcendo para não ser chamada porque
ela longe da minha casa e eu fui de como
né normalmente a gente vai para uma
entrevista de tardezinha e tá e eu fui
de all-star calça jeans rasgada e camisa
da Penélope charmosa e fiz de tudo para
não de nada mas ele precisava de alguém
falasse espanhol e eu tinha morado um
tempo não então acabei passando e o
diabo eu sair de uma reunião eu não
entendia nada que tinha falado era o
business eu só falo assim não tem que
fazer se insere e o workflow e eu falava
o meu Deus ela notava no meu caderninho
falava assim eu não sei nem o que é para
eu fazer eu vou fingir vô que que ele tá
fazendo e tentava fazer igual foi
horrível Eu torcia 360 dias no ano para
chegar e aqueles cinco dias os 5 dias
eram os dias de Natal de Réveillon onde
eu ia ser feliz porque ali era minha
zona de conforto ali eu pertencia ali é
maluco eu fui atrás da felicidade no
lugar e eu só era feliz lá em Curitiba
que estranho eu lembro muito bem do
Natal que eu tava tomando um vinhozinho
e tal com a minha família e eles falando
que que você faz na época eu já
trabalhava com executivos eu tinha que
ligar para presidente de empresas
diretores financeiros e eu tava olhando
assim meu Deus que difícil ligar não
gosto odeio aí quando eu vou contar para
minha família salve era que legal que
chique O que você faz E ela tá bem louca
essa família bem louca mas isso me
despertou uma coisa naquele Natal eu
pensei será que eu não tô vendo alguma
coisa eu tô deixando de ver alguma coisa
que eles tão vendo e vou te incomodado
acho que é pela primeira vez eu fiquei
incomodada falei eu vou tentar ver eu
vou voltar para São Paulo e vou tentar
enxergar o que eles estão enxergando e
como mágica Eu não tomei um café da
manhã diferente eu não jantei diferente
não tomei uma não come espinafre do
Popeye
Mas alguma coisa aconteceu
uau na minha vida aconteceu eu comecei a
trabalhar a trabalhar com raiva Business
review Brasil rdm com a Vivo empresas
das maiores do país Bolsa de Valores
quem era eu a Camila que queria
trabalhar no shopping tava ali aquele
Mundo e quem diria eu trabalhei no
Brasil Chile México Colômbia Miami
e eu voltava me perguntava como foi que
tudo isso aconteceu como aconteceu e aí
eu comecei a investigar acho que a gente
para pouco para olhar as histórias das
nossas famílias né gente senta pouco sua
voz e fala como é que foi a tua história
com os tios como é que foi a tua
história e comecei a olhar para a
história falei realmente a minha família
sempre foi para um lugar para o outro
mas só foram felizes não importava o
lugar Quando eles começaram a olhar para
dentro será que isso é alguma coisa do
Imigrante aí vai a primeira pergunta na
cabeça era Será que isso é coisa de
imigrante quando a gente muda de um
lugar para outro a gente veste essa
camisa the beach mista encontrei dados
muito interessantes por Cuidado que eu
encontrei foi que mais de 35 por cento
da população brasileira e isso antes da
pandemia vive em outro município estão
mudou seja de estado seja de cidade seja
de país mudou
e até aí tudo bem as pessoas que mudem
para onde elas quiserem Mas será que
elas estão mudando com a mentalidade
correta elas estão esperando aquela
placa de boas-vindas e eu descobri Olha
que coisa triste a gente saber mas é
importante que em São Paulo tem mais de
24 mil pessoas em situação de rua e
dessas mais de setenta por cento são
migrantes Será que alguém muda para
morar e mas da contar meu sonho morar
embaixo da ponte eu duvidei falei não
não é possível e eu fui lá conversar com
a galera lá falecido na Da onde você é
né e eu viu ela curiosa muitos
questionamentos onde você é por quê que
isso aconteceu com você e paz meu
encontrei gente com três formações e não
tinha um bom emprego o que que
diferencia quem tem uma bom emprego de
quem não tem ou uma boa oportunidade de
quem não tem essa coisa funciona e eu
comecei a estudar sobre hard Skills e
soft Skills as Skills para quem não sabe
só as características técnicas aquela
que você faz um curso uma o certificado
e a soft Skills são as características
comportamentais
e existe até uma lei viu além da sorte
se você tem as vips quilos que são tipo
assim motivação alegria
inspiração qual se encontra esse tipo de
coisa e eu percebi que isso faz muito
mais diferença do que a cidade seus que
para inclusive você se motive para
estudar que você se motiva para
trabalhar você se motivo para buscar uma
série de coisas Você precisa com essa
soft Skills um dia e falei que maluco e
aí eu li uma frase que me chamou muita
atenção de um psicanalista Carl Jung que
ele dizia quem olha para fora sonha quem
olha para dentro desperta e eu falei
tudo a ver porque não tava lá não tava
em São Paulo a felicidade não tava na
Europa para minha mãe não tava para os
meus avós no Paraná sempre esteve dentro
dele todos tiveram que olhar para dentro
Em algum momento que eu não quero tá
alguma coisa errada que pode acontecer
como a gente pode ser mais protagonista
e na época na época que eu comecei a
pensar assim fazendo uma simples faz o
mundo que eu perguntava no Uber eu
perguntava no trem para todo mundo ouvir
um sotaque diferente falar hahaha você
já mudou você tá isso é feliz não é aí
não sou não tenho oportunidade lá onde
eu trabalho Aonde eu morava e não têm
oportunidade onde eu moro agora eu
falava hahaha porque você tem que olhar
para você mas mais do que ficar fazendo
casa de ferreiro Espeto de pau um dia eu
tava conversando sabe Museu presidente
da empresa onde eu trabalhava e um outro
diretor de uma outra empresa no evento
executiva ele disse ali São Paulo não
tem gente engajada falei ela vem
problema é São Paulo e não é isso eu
queria comprovar tipo de coisas e a
gente teve e ele contou que ele fechou a
parte da equipe de São Paulo fechar um
pedaço e abriu lá no interior da Bahia
falei porque Bahia não tem laço da sua
só tem oportunidade de comércio turismo
e eu queria dar oportunidade onde elas
são mais escassas achei que legal falei
nossa Realmente acho que as pessoas
podem mudar mas se tiver oportunidade
onde ela tá Talvez seja legal também E
aí na época com o presidente da empresa
que eu trabalhava ele falou que era uma
bem isso né foi onde é Sumé você vai
ficar no interior da APA e a 200
quilômetros de João Pessoa que a capital
e quando a gente começou a entrevistar
as pessoas ao dizer assim mas por que
que você tava abrindo aqui ele é
pirâmide alguma coisa e eu percebi o
quanto eles também não estavam prontos
para calça oportunidade eu falei cara
que maluco às vezes a oportunidade está
ali piscando para você você não percebe
porque a gente tá no vestido outro papel
que eu chamo de atores da vida real e eu
pensei não adianta a gente dizer
procura-se pro cidadão cidadão que ele
tem que ser sua melhor versão a gente
tem que dizer para o empresário também e
na época deu super certo a saída para
Sumé da empresa NEC que existe até hoje
é muito legal mas eu falei eu não posso
fazer isso só por essa empresa tem que
ter mais tem que ter tem que ir além e
eu decidi ficar maluca fácil que é doida
fala vou pegar uma mala e vou sair pelo
Brasil com a minha família entrevistando
pessoas e essas pessoas eu vou pegar
essa entrevista para entender as
características comportamentais de cada
lugar e depois de entender não podia ser
sua voz da Camila porque eu sou a pena
perto de tudo isso é só uma é o quinto
maior país do mundo quem era eu para
dizer sobre comportamento a
comportamento b então enviar esses esses
todos esses vídeos esse relatórios por
um grupo de intelectuais
antropólogo filósofo sociólogo e eles
analisariam só que tem que ter atividade
nisso então transformaria tudo isso e
eventos para falar sobre comportamentos
como é que cada um pode ser a sua melhor
versão o seu melhor ator da vida real
hora nós somos pais hora nós somos mães
hora nós somos filhos e eu sei o momento
o seu autor da vida real e aí super
legal né tracei a rota 54 municípios
como é que a gente ia quantos dias 3 e
meses tudo mais e aí ia ser lindo eu ia
mudar o Brasil e eu pensei mas eu digo o
que quando eu chegar para conversar com
essas pessoas como é que eu explico o
projeto como é que eu explico essas
coisas e eu pensei preciso preparar as
pessoas também para receber essa
informação e curiosamente algumas coisas
enxergando né você tava lá sentado
parece que ela não sou um acaso e na
verdade não não sério vai ficar buscando
essas coisas para construir e os
pensamentos e um documentário que eu
recomendo que todos assistam tá repita
Tá disponível no YouTube e ele diz sobre
felicidade sobre como as pessoas
encontram a felicidade e aí eu me
deparei com uma cultura japonesa que eu
tenho um nome chamado karoshi quer
trabalho até morrer a pessoa falar
trabalhar morreu mas como é que isso
acontece de nem mesmo país onde tem o
karoshi tem um conjunto de ilhas chamado
Okinawa onde as pessoas são muito longe
vivas 106 103 anos e trabalha no
trabalho trabalho e Dá super certo e aí
eles diziam e que dá e que e que esse é
o motivo da felicidade e que Gaia a
união de quatro elementos tá é o que eu
gosto de fazer
é o que eu sou bom fazendo que você pode
gostar de água não é bom tudo bem você
treina e tem que ser a união perfeita tá
então que eu gosto sou bom Fazenda como
isso pode se remunerar de alguma forma e
como se faz bem para o mundo só que não
adianta só pensar no seu like gastar
pensei Nossa agora sou feliz e que galho
trazendo português que significa razão
de existir é pelo que você acorda pelo
que essa luta todos os dias mas mais do
que isso é preciso agir e aí eu descobri
também na época psicologia positiva te
deixe 98 vem sendo muito estudada e eles
não eles descobriram que a felicidade
ela tem o percentual cinquenta por cento
é genético Normalmente quando eu falo
isso a pessoa pensa aí
a minha família tem alguém que é meio
ruazinhas é meu pai a boa notícia é que
cinquenta por cento os outros 50 por
cento que são dez porcento situas Gerais
ou seja onde eu vivo com quem eu vivo eu
tenho de vida nada não tô e quarenta por
cento sobre respectivamente pensamento e
atitude não adianta a pensar e não agir
isso não vai fazer a transformação na
sua vida e agora que eu acredito que
você está um pouco mais prontos para eu
desvendar que o mistério dessa mala o
grande segredo eu queria dizer que eu
sempre penso assim
Espelho Espelho Meu
e quem decide o meu futuro sou eu
E aí
Oi e o seu quem decide
é muito obrigada
[Música]
E aí